hi everyone i'm jonathan Tron's and
today i really think i'm gonna stump you
with this tactical puzzle because it's a
very difficult one this time some people
really want a tough one so this is your
chance to really solve a really tough
puzzle I should show it to a grandmaster
he was able to solve it without too much
difficulty so perhaps there's a chance
you guys will be able to solve it so
with that let's go ahead and take a look
alright so here is your puzzle for the
day in this position is this black to
move and go ahead and take your time
here see if you can find the best move
I'll pause for about five seconds but if
you need longer than that go ahead pause
your video and see if you can solve this
really tricky one
okay so here the best move for black is
the move rook to d1 he's fighting for
control over the f2 Square and whites
best move is simply to take back the
rook you would lose much faster after
say F takes e4 due to the move Bishop to
e5 and black has irresistible threats
that white cannot avoid and the King
should get made it very soon so instead
we're gonna look at rook takes d1 and
again go ahead and pause your video see
if you can find the right move here the
best move in this position is Queen to
f2 you could try for example Bishop to
e5 but this fails to f4 and if you check
now with the Queen and you play Queen e2
white can actually give up the rook with
the move h3 and after you take it's true
that you've picked up a little bit of a
material but the Queen on b7 is doing a
fantastic job and white should be able
to hold on to this position because he
will be winning back some material in
the near future alright we will return
to the move Queen to f2 okay hopefully
you see how to follow up Queen e2 and
now I can connect his rooks with Bishop
d2 and hopefully you can see this move
Knight f2 and you're gonna take on d1
with your knight so after the King moves
Knight d1
now objectively the best move here is
Queen to a6 which is a very bad sign for
white because you would just take the
queen and if they take your knight
you can even play Queen to e2
guaranteeing that you're gonna win back
a lot of material here so this is no way
for a human to try to save this position
so instead we'll accept the more human
move which is h3 just getting some lift
for the King but how would you continue
the attack with black hair again the
simple move is best Queen takes d2 and
white you can play a few things here but
let's examine Queen takes c6 I think
that's you know I move that a human
would consider and now how will what
black cap off his attack here Queen
takes III and the King can go either to
h2 or h1 it won't make much of a
difference now Queen to e1 king h2 and
hopefully you can find the move that
will really finish them off Bishop to e5
and now all white can do is block with
his pawns and suddenly he will have to
accept his faith so in a position like
this hopefully you see the finishing
move Knight to e3 a very picturesque
checkmate thank you guys for watching
hopefully I was able to stump a lot of
you let me know how you did in the
comments below were you able to find it
and go ahead and please click on the
subscribe button so you can see more
great content just like this